on soir guillaume blot merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rtl france lors de
son investiture alassane ouattara donc
appelé ses opposants au dialogue en vue
des élections législatives
est ce une main tendue par le président
réélu
oui bonjour madame c'est bien évidemment
cela va dans le bon sens je pense c'est
surtout que cela répond aussi à la à la
demande de l'opposition elle-même en les
collant bédié dans son dernier message à
demander où est surtout remplacer le cnt
le conseil national par un dialogue
il a appelé à un dialogue donc je pense
aussi que cela pendant le bon sens alors
l'opposition elle continue en tout cas
de deux de contester le résultat du
scrutin présidentiel
on a du mal à imaginer le futur
politique dans ce contexte
oui c'était un contexte difficile dans
la mesure où dans son appel ou dans les
propositions qu'il a dernièrement fait
le président bédié il a demandé une rue
une nouvelle organisation des élections
il ne reconnaissait pas la légitimité du
président alassane ouattara
aujourd'hui je pense que cela va être
très très difficile dans la mesure où
comme vous le savez il vient de prêter
serment
cela est aujourd'hui t il va falloir
entrer aujourd'hui dans un fond du débat
c'est à dire vers un dialogue comme ils
sont ils appellent tous d'ailleurs
inclusif un dialogue politique fort pour
cela il ya des préalables qui sont
posées par l'opposition
quelles sont ces préalables pour nos
téléspectateurs qui n'y auraient
notamment la libération immédiate et
sans condition de tous les opposants à
reste à arrêter aujourd'hui écroués com
[Musique]
pascal affi n'guessan le bras droit de
monsieur henri konan-bédié kakou
guikahue et bien d'autres je pense à
d'autres députés des gens cassent terrer
comme les moules lobognon hausse de 10
euros est aussi le retour des exilés
politiques pensent à au président
laurent gbagbo guillaume soro d'écouter
tout le monde
des exigences qui vont être satisfaites
selon vous selon ma lecture que ce
dialogue est un aboutissement meilleur
où qu'ils aillent dans le bon sens le
président ouattara devrait aujourd'hui
faire la job ouverture sinon beaucoup
fait preuve de beaucoup de souplesse
vis-à-vis de ses opposants mais aussi et
surtout ce qu'il faudra comprendre
est ce que cette opposition sera t elle
capable de faire bloc unique pour faire
plier le président ouattara a ses
exigences
là aussi c'est une nouvelle question qui
se pose si tel est le cas
bien évidemment je pense que le witch le
président ouattara devra se plier à ces
exécutions sinon il pourra orienter les
eaux les débats ont mis le sang il ya
même un mystère de la réconciliation qui
va être créée promesse du président
réélu effet d'annonce selon vous cela va
vraiment faire avancer les choses dans
le sens de la réconciliation lui parle
d'un ministère de réconciliation
l'opposition parle de la remise en route
ou en place de la cdvr
c'est à dire qu'il y avait été ce que
mécanisme qui avait été mis en place et
dirigé par l'ancien premier ministre
charles konan banny
alors est ce qu'on parle de la même
chose là aussi il faut il faut accorder
les violons
il ya aussi un autre grand point qui est
important c'est tout de suite
il faudrait qu'ils envoient un message
fort à son opposition bien évidemment il
ya ces arrestations y compris un autre
candidat à la présidence affi n'guessan
il ya des députés qui sont incarcérés
il faudrait le président ouattara
devrait automatiquement dès le 2 mai
matin envoyer un message fort à
l'opposition ou justement que cette
annonce de ce ministère à la
réconciliation ne soit pas comme vous le
dites en effet d'annonce dernière
question alassane ouattara avec la règle
la côte d'ivoire avait choisi la
démocratie en serait que tu as été élu à
accra 1 14% des voix au premier tour
vous êtes d'accord avec ce diagnostic on
peut vraiment parler clairement d'une
élection démocratique selon vous moi je
vous dis réussir un camp qu'observateur
de la vie politique ouest africaine et
on a eu cette grande période des coups
de force militaire et aujourd'hui on est
passé aux forces militaires allaient
coup de force institutionnel ce mot un
coup ko et a pris toute la région
il ya des mécanismes ce soit en change à
la veille des élections les règles du
jeu donc la constitution
donc on passe en force par un mécanisme
les juges sont à la solde du tenant du
pouvoir et le la ceni donc cet organe
qui est chargée est indépendante ou à
organiser de nouvelles élections pareil
donc aussi là je dirais qu'il faut
aujourd'hui revoir la question de la
démocratie dans toute la sous région en
est un exemple le cas de la guinée qui
ressemble trait pour trait à celui la
côte d'ivoire monsieur ouattara disait
t-il que il a dû être obligé contraint
de revenir sur sa décision
parce que son défunt de désigner et et
était décédé mais là n'est pas une
raison valable pour remettre en question
d'une constitution
cela aussi fait débat pour vous
remarqué dans la vie politique française
est même le premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste
olivier faur en a appelé il a dit que la
candidature de monsieur ouattara était
anticonstitutionnelle donc la question
de la démocratie et les touche pas
seulement la la côte d'ivoire mais
touchant bon nombre de pays ouest
africain que je dirais africain et là
encore une fois il faut respecter les
règles qui sont données et tant qu'on ne
les respectent pas la démocratie ne
serait pas respectée c'est beaucoup
guillaume blot ancien conseiller aux
affaires politiques aux nations unies
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france pour évoquer cette élection en
côte d'ivoire